c'est sous l'oeil attentif de son coach
que les haines s'élance avec java 2,6
frérot sa ponette sur le parcours de 12
obstacles organisé dimanche dernier par
le centre équestre de bois d'arcy
résultat qu'en bon par contre malgré
deux erreurs
j'ai l'impression qu'elle avait un petit
peu peur de la pluie mais ça allait mais
après c'est peut-être un peu de ma faute
si si elle a dérobé
j'ai pas assez médian mais j'ai pas
assez écarté maman j'aime bien concourir
et la dernière fois j'avais raté mon
parcours alors je n'allais pas rester
sur ça ça fait partie du processus
d'apprentissage comme à l'école faut
qu'ils commencent par des petits
parcours faire des erreurs et puis et
puis essayer de pas les répéter
ce qui compte c'est d'apprendre quelque
chose et comme je dis aux élèves
on apprend plus quand on perd que quand
on gagne parmi les 60 partants dimanche
matin des cavaliers yvelinois de
différents clubs des amateurs qui
enchaînait un parcours de sauts
d'obstacles pour la première fois tout
comme des compétiteurs de club en élite
qui venait s'entraîner sur de gros
obstacles en prévision du championnat de
france de cet été ont fait ce concours
un petit peu pour éventuellement donner
des qualifications à ceux qui en
manquait pour la motte beuvron sont les
championnats de france
et en plus pour clôturer un petit peu
l'année ça
ça donne un but de travail tout au long
de l'année il s'agissait du troisième
concours de sauts d'obstacles organisé
cette année par le centre équestre de
bois d'arcy